hi I'm Ben hi I'm I'm Ed's and today
we're making one of my favorite
childhood dishes chicken shawarma it's
actually one of my childhood dishes also
I remember going by the there like
someone like actually pizza places in
New York would also have the schwarmann
fun another guys I feel like shawarma is
to Aleppo what pizza is to New York I
just vividly remember the memories of my
mom sending me to the store I have the
chicken and then you have this garlic
sauce which will be making later today
and that's the magic reason that's so
good we met last year yeah exactly yeah
at World Refugee day at the UN because
I've been doing some work with the UNHCR
UN refugee agency do you were reading a
poem there yes her poem called I thank
you a letter from the bomb that visited
my home 11 years ago so it was from the
perspective of the bomb talking to me
after all these years I was 8 years old
this was in 2006 so we had to flee Iraq
in 2006 we know he just got on a bus and
as a kid you don't really realize these
things you don't understand that you
might be leaving your home for the very
last time in the first place you lived
in the US was where Sioux Falls South
Dakota Wow yeah and there's the Sherman
Sioux Falls it's not very good we moved
around a few times in the US and sure
Mo's wasn't always right there you know
living in the States and having to
create this dish at home as opposed to
getting it down the street I should ask
my dad why did we make life choices
based on where Sean was readily real
pretty good yeah
after case yeah it has a little a little
zing at the end it's kind of perfect
right and in seriously how did you guys
end up in South Dakota when you flee
your home and then you applied for
refugee status it's a very very very
long process we found out one summer day
we're in Dublin I remember I was in my
bedroom my mom was in living room and
all of a sudden I just hear screaming oh
my god she find out that I did that
thing yesterday you know and then I walk
in and then she can I just puts the
phone down and she's like I'm I'd were
going to America when they told her on
the way they said you have four one-way
tickets to Sioux Falls South Dakota idea
of what a refugee is in people's minds
there's an image there that that doesn't
really correlate with reality it's not
something you choose who they're looking
for an opportunity just to have a life
exactly and when we first came to the
States you know my parents had to find
jobs they had to figure out how to make
ends meet and Americans have to do that
as well we have to start thinking of the
common thread through these experiences
distances have to be this foreign
foreign thing sure Jessica
is this like amazing familiarity that
happens we're like right mid-bite you're
transported somewhere else and you're
reminded of not only just like the food
but the people that prepared it no and
really just I'm just like struck by the
how much I like to eat
[Music]